Si Auguste vivait de nos jours,
nous ne pourrions pas plus l'aider qu'Aloïs il y a 114 ans.
Aloïs était le docteur Aloïs Alzheimer.
Et Auguste Deter
fut la première patiente à être diagnostiquée
avec ce que nous appelons aujourd'hui la maladie d'Alzheimer.
Depuis 1901, la médecine a incroyablement avancé.
Nous avons découvert les antibiotiques et les vaccins
pour nous protéger des infections,
de nombreux traitements pour le cancer, des antirétroviraux pour le VIH,
les statines pour les maladies cardiaques et bien d'autres choses.
Mais nous n'avons fait aucun progrès dans le traitement de l'Alzheimer.
Je fais partie d'une équipe de scientifiques
qui travaille depuis plus de 10 ans pour trouver un traitement à l'Alzheimer.
J'y pense constamment.
Alzheimer affecte aujourd'hui 40 millions de personnes dans le monde.
Mais d'ici 2050, elle affectera 150 millions de personnes --
ce qui, au passage, inclura beaucoup d'entre vous.
Si vous espérez vivre jusqu'à 85 ans ou plus,
le risque que vous ayez Alzheimer sera de près d'un sur deux.
En d'autres mots, selon les statistiques, vous passerez votre âge d'or
soit souffrant d'Alzheimer,
soit aidant un ami ou un être cher atteint de cette maladie.
Aux États-Unis uniquement,
Alzheimer coûte déjà 200 milliards de dollars chaque année.
Un dollar sur cinq des assurances maladies est dépensé pour Alzheimer.
C'est aujourd'hui la maladie la plus coûteuse,
et les coûts devraient être multipliés par 5 d'ici 2050,
plus la génération du baby-boom vieillira.
Cela pourrait vous surprendre que, dit simplement,
Alzheimer soit l'un des plus gros défis médicaux et sociaux de notre génération.
Mais nous avons fait relativement peu pour traiter le problème.
Aujourd'hui, parmi les 10 premières causes de mortalité dans le monde,
Alzheimer est la seule que nous ne pouvons pas éviter, guérir ni même ralentir.
Nous comprenons moins Alzheimer que les autres maladies
parce que nous avons investi moins de temps et d'argent dans la recherche.
Le gouvernement des États-Unis dépense chaque année 10 fois plus
pour la recherche contre le cancer que pour Alzheimer
malgré le fait qu'Alzheimer nous coûte plus
et soit la cause d'un nombre équivalent de morts que le cancer.
Le manque de ressources découle d'une cause plus fondamentale :
le manque de sensibilisation.
Parce que voici ce que peu savent mais que tous devraient savoir :
Alzheimer est une maladie et nous pouvons la guérir.
Pendant la majorité des 114 dernières années,
tout le monde, scientifiques inclus, confondaient Alzheimer et vieillissement.
Nous pensions que devenir sénile
était normal et inévitable avec le vieillissement.
Mais nous n'avons qu'à regarder une image
d'un cerveau âgé sain comparé à celui d'un patient d'Alzheimer
pour voir les réels dégâts physiques engendrés par la maladie.
En plus de déclencher une perte importante de la mémoire et des capacités mentales,
les dégâts causés par Alzheimer sur le cerveau
réduisent significativement l'espérance de vie et sont toujours fatals.
Le docteur Alzheimer avait trouvé d'étranges plaques et enchevêtrements
dans le cerveau d'Auguste il y a un siècle.
Pendant près d'un siècle, nous ne savions presque rien à ce sujet.
Aujourd'hui, nous savons qu'ils sont faits de molécules de protéine.
Vous pouvez imaginer une molécule de protéine
comme étant une feuille de papier qui se plie en un origami élaboré.
Certains endroits de la feuille sont collants.
Quand elle est correctement pliée, ces endroits sont à l'intérieur.
Mais parfois quelque chose se passe mal, ces endroits collants sont à l'extérieur.
Cela entraîne les différentes molécules à se coller entre elles,
s'agglutinant et formant finalement des plaques et enchevêtrements.
C'est ce que nous voyons dans le cerveau des patients d'Alzheimer.
A l'Université de Cambridge, nous avons passé ces 10 dernières années,
à essayer de comprendre comment fonctionne cette anomalie.
Il y a de nombreuses étapes,
et il est complexe d'identifier quelle étape bloquer --
c'est comme désamorcer une bombe.
Couper un fil pourrait ne rien faire.
En couper d'autres pourrait faire exploser la bombe.
Nous devons trouver quelle étape bloquer,
puis créer un médicament qui fasse cela.
Jusqu'à récemment, nous avons principalement
coupé des fils en espérant que tout aille bien.
Nous avons maintenant mis ensemble des compétences variées --
médecins, biologistes, généticiens,
chimistes, physiciens, ingénieurs et mathématiciens.
Ensemble, nous avons réussi à identifier une étape cruciale dans le processus
et nous testons un nouveau type de médicaments qui bloquerait cette étape
et arrêterait la maladie.
Laissez-moi vous montrer certains de nos derniers résultats.
Personne en dehors de notre labo ne les a encore vus.
Regardons ce qu'il s'est passé quand nous avons testé
ces nouveaux médicaments sur des vers.
Ce sont de vers sains,
vous voyez qu'ils bougent normalement.
Ces vers-là, au contraire,
ont en eux des molécules de protéine collantes --
comme les humains ayant Alzheimer.
Vous pouvez voir qu'ils sont clairement malades.
Mais si nous donnons nos nouveaux médicaments
à ces vers à un stage précoce,
nous observons qu'ils sont sains et ont une durée de vie normale.
Ce n'est qu'un résultat initial positif, mais des recherches comme celle-ci
nous montrent qu'Alzheimer est une maladie que nous pouvons comprendre et traiter.
Après 114 ans d'attente,
il y a finalement un vrai espoir de réussir d'ici 10 ou 20 ans.
Mais pour faire grandir cet espoir, pour vaincre Alzheimer,
nous avons besoin d'aide.
Il n'est pas question de scientifiques comme moi --
mais de vous.
Nous avons besoin de vous pour dire qu'Alzheimer est une maladie
et que si nous essayons, nous pouvons la vaincre.
Dans le cas d'autres maladies,
les patients et leurs familles ont mené la lutte pour plus de recherche,
ils ont mis la pression sur les gouvernements,
l'industrie pharmaceutique, les scientifiques et les régulateurs.
C'était essentiel pour l'avancée du traitement du VIH, dans les années 80.
Aujourd'hui, nous voyons la même action pour vaincre le cancer.
Mais les patients d'Alzheimer sont souvent incapables de se faire entendre.
Et leurs familles, les victimes cachées s'occupant d'eux, jour et nuit,
sont souvent trop épuisées pour défendre leur cause.
Cela dépend vraiment de vous.
Alzheimer est rarement une maladie génétique.
Toute personne avec un cerveau court un risque.
Aujourd'hui, il y a 40 millions de patients comme Auguste,
qui ne peuvent initier le changement dont ils ont besoin.
Aidez-les à s'exprimer,
et aidez en exigeant un traitement.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)